Một người 2 biệt tháng 2, đại dục quan Mỹ tại Israel sắc nhận.
Bông ngoại sông Mỹ đã cho phát nhận viên chính phủ không thủ diện thiết iếu cùng thân nhân
Zei Coi Israel, giấu các dùi gió an ninh sát ăn, tôi qua này đồng thời quyến cáo những người còn lại
Ninh cần nhất dự đi khi các chuyên bài thương mại vẫn còn đang hoạt động.
Các đại dục quan khác cũng nhận mạnh những người của Newcastle đi cần thực hiện ngay
cho một cạnh quyết cơ chỉ vì chuyển tăng cao và tình hình ăn ninh có thể diễn biến phức tạm.
Cùng thuy điểm một số cuo sai như ổ sư liêa, ba làm thuy định and độ và cân đưa đa, cũng nhính trong sơ tăng nhân viên
và đưa ra quyến cáo công dân dự khỏi các khu vực có quý cơ liệu tháng tháng.
Tao viến những quý lưu đu quốc bài tỏ lo ngại, về khả năng leo thân quân sự trong khu vực
cơ hỏi các bên kiểm chế, các cạnh báo đưa dứt ra khi đầm phẳng Mỹ i番 tại Chinabh
vừa kích thúc quân ngay mà chưa đặt đu phá ngào, chúng khi Washington tích tục xem xác khu phương ăn quân sự và điều động lực lượng.
Vy et sư rào cũng còn những động thái chuẩn bị các phương ăn chưa dân thường.
Tất cả những tiếng hiệu đang xem làm dây lên quan ngại,
về ăn ninh khu vực trung đồng trong những ngày tới.